Die Welt wandelt sich -
auch jene der Winzer.
Für manche Schweizer Weinbauern
steht die Zukunft auf dem Spiel.
In Genf will Damien Mermoud
gegen den Rat seines Vaters
ins Geschäft einsteigen.
Er sagte mir: "Mach was anderes!"
Wer das mit Leidenschaft macht,
opfert leicht
sein ganzes Leben dafür.
Im Lavaux hat Pierre Monachon
den Betrieb
seinem Sohn Basile übergeben.
Mit seinen Kindern zu arbeiten ist
genauso heikel wie mit seinem Vater.
Jetzt habe ich das Sagen,
aber sicher müssen wir wachsen.
Im Tessin
wird das riesige Weingut Tamborini
nach Generationen
der Männerherrschaft
nun von dieser jungen Frau,
Valentina, geleitet.
Als Frau hat man es
in diesem Metier nicht leicht.
Es ist nach wie vor
eine Männerdomäne.
In Graubünden
strebt Irene Grünenfelder
gegen den Willen ihrer Kinder
das Bio-Zertifikat an.
Es ist einfach Schwachsinn!
Auf dem Weg hoch zum Weingut
denke ich mir immer:
wunderschön, aber stark gefährdet.
Und im Wallis führt Marion Granges
mit aller Kraft
eines der Vorzeigegüter.
Sie ist die Seele
des Weinguts Beudon.
Die Winzerin der Berggipfel,
die einen Nachfolger sucht.
Für diese fünf Winzerinnen und Winzer
ist der Jahresverlauf
voller Ungewissheit.
Vier Jahreszeiten.
* Krähen *
Es ist Winter in der Schweiz,
auch im Genfer Weinland liegt Schnee.
Zeit für Reparaturen.
In der Scheune
treffen wir Luc und Damien Mermoud,
Vater und Sohn
der dritten Winzergeneration.
Kannst du das Ding mal stützen?
Ja, oder sollen wir nachher ...
Aber nicht unter ... - Oder
wir schweissen eine Mutter an.
Wir nehmen ein Lager
und bohren durch
und schweissen direkt darunter
eine Mutter an.
Was?
Wir machen die Öffnung grösser,
schweissen die Mutter an
und drehen das Ding. So klappt's.
Damien ist pragmatisch.
Mit 19 schloss er
die Mechanikerausbildung ab,
und ich fragte ihn:
"Was willst du jetzt tun?"
"Willst du Autos reparieren?"
Er schaute mich völlig perplex an
und sagte:
"Nein, nein,
ich will doch hier arbeiten!"
Ich kam zurück und wollte hier
als Winzer einsteigen,
aber er sagte klipp und klar, ich
solle mir eine andere Arbeit suchen.
Er hatte sich schon immer
Gedanken darüber gemacht.
Er wollte nicht, dass ich mit 60 mal
so kaputt und verbraucht bin wie er.
Das Wetter hat man dauernd im Auge.
Mein Vater beobachtete es täglich.
Er starb am 15. Juli 2016 mit
94 Jahren eines natürlichen Todes.
Am Tag zuvor hatte er mich noch
gefragt: "Wie geht's den Reben?"
"Irgendwelche Krankheiten?
Wie machen sich die Trauben?"
"Wie dies und wie das?"
So läuft das,
und Damien wollte ich es ersparen.
Und trotzdem
hat sich Damien dafür entschieden.
Seit einigen Jahren
führt er den Betrieb,
und dieses Jahr ist wegweisend.
Celle qui n'a pas de pattes
au centre.
Je n'ai pas le dernier ecrou, la.
Il est deja rentre?
(Pierre Monachon)
Also, wir schneiden die Reben,
und du kümmerst dich
um die Lehrlinge.
(Basile) Ja, klar.
Auch Pierre übergibt an seinen Sohn.
Basile soll ich nun um alles kümmern.
Der Boden ist knapp im Lavaux.
Sie haben nur 3 ha zur Verfügung.
Mit seinen Kindern zu arbeiten ist
genauso heikel wie mit seinem Vater.
Es kommt auf das Gleiche raus.
Der Weinbau
hat sich ständig weiterentwickelt
und zwar in praktisch allen Ländern,
in denen Wein angebaut wird.
Eines Tages sagte er:
"Ich hab's satt. Ich gehe weg."
Ich schlug vor, dass wir
ein, zwei Jahre zusammenarbeiten
und ich ihm dann
das Ruder überlassen würde.
Wunderbares Wetter.
Ende Februar und solch gute,
frische Temperaturen.
Was für ein Glück!
1990 war es Ende Februar sehr warm
für die Jahreszeit.
Das ist nie gut.
Die Knospen
brachen Ende März zu früh auf,
und wir mussten gespannt
bis zum 1. Mai warten,
weil bis dann einfach
ein Frostrisiko besteht.
Ja, und letztes Jahr war es eiskalt.
Mein Vater
ist ein wandelndes Klimalexikon.
Seine Meinung ist immer interessant.
Er sagt Dinge wie: "Es ist 20 °C
warm und es hat 30 mm geregnet."
"Das ist nicht gut für uns,
egal was du auch tust."
Solche Aussagen sind wichtig,
weil man sich dadurch
vieles ersparen kann.
Wir tragen die Last der Jahre mit,
d.h., wir haben Lebenserfahrung.
Man kann nicht einfach sagen:
"Ich überlass dir den Betrieb.
Hier meine Kundenliste."
"Ich bin dann mal weg."
So geht das nicht.
Eine Betriebsübergabe
muss doch richtig begleitet werden,
damit es der Nachfolger
leichter hat.
Den eigenen Stil zu entwickeln,
ohne die Tradition zu verwässern:
Darum geht es Basile jetzt.
* Sanfte Musik *
An diesem Tag im Februar
besuchen David und Gaiane
ihre Grossmutter Marion
auf ihrem Weingut Beudon
auf 900 m Höhe oberhalb von Fully.
Nur diese Seilbahn führt hier hoch.
Salut, mamie.
- Salut, David.
Oh, salut, David. Ca va?
- Oui.
Tu vien en velo?
Salut, mamie.
- Ciao.
Ca va? Mes braves.
Wir gehen raus, David.
Weisst du, wie alt diese Reben sind?
Sie waren schon 1971 da, als Opa
Jacky das Weingut Beudon kaufte.
Als ich hierherkam,
versprach mir Jacques,
dass ich mein Flötenstudium
weitermachen könne.
Aber Beudon hat gesiegt,
und ich gab das Studium auf.
Wenigstens habe ich meine
drei Töchter beeinflussen können.
Sie sind alle Musikerinnen geworden
und nicht Winzerinnen.
Beim Rebschnitt muss das Auge
hier vorne sein, siehst du?
Es müssen zwei Augen sein.
Schau, hier hinten ist eins
und eins hier, zack!
Das lassen und hier schneiden?
Nein, vor der Wunde muss es sein.
Dann nimmst du das.
So kommen zwei heraus.
Egal wenn es kleiner ist
als das andere.
Siehst du, so geht das.
Das ist er Walliser Rebschnitt.
Meine Töchter
konnten ihren Beruf frei wählen.
Sie helfen mir aber, so gut sie
können, weil ich ihnen gesagt habe:
"Wenn Beudon bestehen bleiben soll,
schaffe ich das nicht alleine."
Willst du wieder runter?
Wann musst du dort sein?
(David) Ich treffe meine Freunde
um 13.30 Uhr.
Du wolltest doch zur Fasnacht.
Aber erst gibt es etwas zu essen.
David und Gaiane
müssen runter zur Fasnacht.
Aber mit leerem Magen
lässt sie sie natürlich nicht gehen.
Voila.
Wollt ihr beide euch nicht setzen?
Ciao, David. Viel Spass an
der Fasnacht. Danke für den Besuch.
Danke.
Ciao, Gaiane, guten Appetit.
Danke für das Essen.
- Lass David auch einen Tisch.
Wie im Restaurantwagen. Schmeckt's?
Ja, lecker!
Alors, ciao. Und seid schön brav.
David, keine Hundekacke
in Briefkästen schmeissen, gell.
Ciao, ciao.
- (Gaiane) Danke.
Bon apres-midi.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ohne Jacky, der vor 18 Monaten starb,
stellt sich die Frage der Nachfolge.
Marion Granges
und ihren zwei Angestellten
steht ein Übergangsjahr bevor.
* Imposante Musik *
Immer durch die Rebberge
bis ans andere Ende der Schweiz
landen wir in Graubünden.
Hier führt Irene den Betrieb.
Ihr Sohn Johannes steckt mitten
zwischen zwei Praktika im Ausland.
Ich finde es toll,
zusammen zu arbeiten.
Ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass Johannes Winzer macht.
Es interessierte ihn nicht.
Plötzlich fand er,
er wolle das machen.
Ich sagte ihm: "Überlege es dir noch
einen Monat, dann schauen wir."
Aber jetzt ist er voll dabei.
Er hat grossen Spass.
Das ist etwas ganz anderes.
Aber schau,
was willst du hier machen?
Du kannst diesen Ast nicht anbinden
mit diesem Stockabstand.
Wir könnten versuchen,
diesen hervorzuziehen.
Ein Bogen mit diesem,
dieser geht nach vorne.
Das ist nicht optimal.
Bei den Grünenfelders
zeigt man noch Charakter.
Man hält zusammen, auch wenn man
nicht immer gleicher Meinung ist.
Irene will dieses Jahr
das Bio-Zertifikat haben,
was nicht bei allen in der Familie
ankommt.
Ich hätte mich nicht
für Bio angemeldet.
Ich hätte es gemacht, weil ...
Wir bewirtschaften biologisch,
sind aber nicht zertifiziert,
weil ich gewisse Dinge
beim biologischen Weinbau
etwas fragwürdig empfinde.
Man muss sich fragen,
ob es so viel Sinn macht
im Vergleich zum konventionellen.
Wenn man Bio als Marketing miss-
braucht, kann man es sein lassen.
Ich bin überzeugt, dass es am Ende
den Reben und dem Boden guttut.
Vor fünf Jahren habe ich begonnen,
ohne Herbizide zu arbeiten.
Auch beim Boden Bio.
Vor etwa vier Jahren machte ich die
ersten Versuche beim Pflanzenschutz.
Es macht süchtig. Einmal angefangen,
kann man nicht mehr zurück.
* Rasante Rockmusik *
Im Tessin
steckt das bekannte Weingut Tamborini
auch in einem Übergang
von Vater zu ... Tochter Valentina.
Es kommt mir vor, als wäre ich
schon 14 Jahre im Geschäft,
nicht erst vier.
"Zusehen, zuhören und lernen",
sagt mein Vater immer.
Aber er macht mir
keine Vorschriften.
Ich habe sowieso
meinen eigenen Willen.
Dennoch respektiere ich,
was er über die Jahre
aufgebaut und mir beigebracht hat.
Hier hat Valentina
ihren ersten Weisswein gemacht,
ihren ersten eigenen Jahrgang
aus Trauben von dieser Parzelle.
Mit dabei ist Pierre,
ihr Chefagronom.
Okay, ich schneide also hier?
Ja.
Yeah.
- Mach nur!
Hier hat der Frost zugeschlagen.
Wir nehmen alles weg.
Das war der Frost im letzten Jahr.
Schau, hier!
* Handy *
Richtig.
Wir müssen etwas zurückschneiden.
Das ist wichtig.
Ja, bitte?
Nein, haben wir schon gemacht.
Bereits etikettiert.
Ja, ich kontrolliere es.
Danke, Antonella.
Allora.
Antonella sagt,
das Etikett sei falsch.
Ich muss es kontrollieren.
Tut mir leid.
Kein Problem. Alles klar. Geh nur!
Ho capito.
Das Problem mit dem Etikett
hat Vorrang.
Die Reben werden später geschnitten.
Valentina muss schnell zum Drucker.
Hier, 12,6, das war der Credi 2013,
13,3 der Credi 2015
und 13,6 der Vivi 2017.
Dann stimmt's ja.
- No.
Sie haben Gradation 12,6 gedruckt.
Dann ist es ihr Fehler.
No.
* Beklemmende Musik *
... al terzo fermarci.
- Io stavo seguendo un attimo ...
# ... tonight.
Guten Tag, Tamborini am Apparat.
Ich hatte Ihnen
eines mit 12,6 gegeben.
Wie kann das passieren?
Credi 2015
müsste 13,6 gedruckt werden.
Ich habe so viel im Kopf,
da kann ich mich nicht
an alle Details erinnern.
* Beklemmende Musik *
Ich weiss nicht,
ob ich heute Nacht schlafen kann.
Quelli che abbiamo fatto,
andiamo a metterli giu un po ... No!
Avete delle cassette dove si possono
mettere dentro le bottiglie?
In Rivaz erholen sich die Reben,
während die Traubenernte
des vergangenen Herbstes
verarbeitet wird.
Basile und sein Vater
filtrieren den Wein
und verleihen ihm so
seinen Charakter.
Die Filtration
ist eine heikle Sache.
Da ist ziemlich viel Bodensatz
im Tank.
Wir müssen aufpassen,
dass der Filter nicht verstopft.
Es darf keine Luft rein.
Es darf nicht überlaufen usw.
All diese Details sind wichtig.
Der Tank Manchettes ist fertig.
Wir machen mit dem Tank Planta
weiter.
Da es zwei sind,
machen wir jetzt die Assemblage.
Also, der hier
und der dort und Tank 14.
Wenn man 35 Jahre lang der Chef war,
dann ist man einfach der Chef.
Wenn man sagen muss:
"Mach, was du willst. Mir egal.
Wenn du meinst, kein Problem",
dann wird's kompliziert,
dann muss man seine Schnauze halten.
Aber das ist normal.
So läuft es halt.
Schön, wenn man sich einigen kann.
Basile packt an, während Pierre
sich anderen Dingen widmet.
Er ist Vizepräsident
der Fete des Vignerons
und hier unterwegs zu
einer Vorbereitungssitzung in Vevey.
Valentina sucht eine Lösung
für das Etikett.
Wie jeden Tag
ist ihr Vater Claudio im Büro.
Das übliche Nebeneinander
mit dem Seniorchef.
* Handy *
Ciao, Mary.
Findest du die Lösung gut?
Kannst du mir einen Gefallen tun?
Könntest du Bettini fragen,
ob es so geht?
Si. Ich möchte die Flaschen
nicht mehr bewegen.
Sie sollen herkommen
und das Problem lösen.
Ich konnte letzte Nacht
nicht schlafen.
Ciao, meine Liebe.
Ciao.
Also, noch einmal.
* Fetzige Rockmusik *
Im Weinkeller unter dem Büro
reift die letztjährige Merlot-Ernte
in Eichenfässern heran.
Es wird über den werdenden Wein
diskutiert.
* Valentina lacht. *
Das ist dasselbe Holz
wie bei der ersten Probe.
Das riecht man.
Piu indietro. Ma ...
- Ah!
Und das ist?
- Immer noch der Gleiche.
Der Gleiche.
- Aber er ist schon rund und weich.
Ja, sehr intensiv.
Als Frau hat man es
in diesem Metier nicht leicht.
Es ist nach wie vor
eine Männerdomäne.
Was Frauen sagen,
mag weniger Gewicht haben,
aber wir müssen unsere Meinung
äussern und auch zuhören können
und uns ständig weiterentwickeln.
Strategiesitzung
der Winzerbruderschaft.
Es geht um die Finanzen
der Fete des Vignerons.
Comme ca on peut se sortir.
Fakt ist, dass unser Gesamtbudget
heute bei 125 Mio. steht.
Man kann es drehen und wenden,
wie man will,
aber 100
dürfen wir nicht übersteigen.
Wir haben alle Möglichkeiten
ausgeschöpft.
Wenn wir von 100 Mio. ausgehen,
dann werden die Eintrittspreise
durch das Budget,
d.h. die Anzahl Vorstellungen
bestimmt.
Mit den aktuellen Preisen
und bei vollem Haus
brauchen wir 24 Vorstellungen.
Es liegen bereits
sieben Einsprachen vor.
Und die Gemeinde und die Stadt Vevey
verlangen von uns,
die Pläne auszuschreiben, was es
in der Schweiz noch nie gegeben hat.
Wir sollten die Gemeinde
dazu bringen,
eine öffentliche Sitzung
einzuberufen,
bei der wir der Allgemeinheit und
den Gegnern alles vorstellen können.
Jean möchte eine Sitzung mit
den Gegnern und der Allgemeinheit.
Ich würde lieber nur die Gegner
und die Gemeindevertreter treffen.
Mehr nicht. Sonst verzetteln wir uns
und finden keine Lösung.
Finde ich auch.
- Einverstanden.
Ja, aber dann müsst ihr hingehen,
ihr kennt das künstlerische Programm
und könnt das Fest
ins richtige Licht rücken.
Das kann nicht irgendjemand tun,
nicht einmal ich. - Ach was!
Es können zwei, drei Freiwillige
dabei sein,
die eine Ahnung
von der Geschichte haben,
aber an der Spitze müssen
die stehen, die sich gut auskennen.
Abgemacht:
Pierre wird das in die Hand nehmen.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Ihre Insel der Glückseligkeit
verlässt Marion Granges selten.
Aber heute Abend nimmt sie
an einer öffentlichen Weinprobe
mit einer alten Freundin teil,
der bekannten Winzerin
Marie-Therese Chappaz.
Dieser Abend
ist zwei Grandes Dames gewidmet,
die Sie wohl alle kennen:
nämlich Marion Granges
und Marie-Therese Chappaz.
Auf dem Weg zum Weingut
denke ich mir immer:
wunderschön, aber stark gefährdet.
Um das zu verstehen,
muss man Marion besuchen.
Marion, die das mit ihrem Mann Jacky
gemacht hat,
der vor zwei Jahren gestorben ist.
Oder sind es schon drei?
Zwei.
- Am 10. Juni 2016.
Er hatte immer
einen Trick auf Lager.
Er hat dem Walliser Weinbau
unglaublich viel gebracht.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Und Marion und er haben Beudon
zu dem gemacht, was es heute ist.
Ich bin voll motiviert.
Ich versuche, Marion dazu
zu bringen, das Weingut zu erhalten.
Manchmal sieht man den wahren Wert
der Dinge nicht und sagt sich:
"Nein, es ist mir zu viel."
Aber im Grunde genommen
wird man davon getragen.
Ich bin überzeugt: Marion
ist die Seele des Weinguts Beudon.
* Melancholische Klänge *
In Jenins bekommt Irene
Besuch von ihren zwei Kindern:
Sohn Johannes und Tochter Europa.
Machen wir ein frühes Abendessen?
Entschuldigung, ich bin zu spät.
- Ja, wir haben Hunger.
Hallo, Europa.
- Hallo.
Die Kartoffeln
brauchen noch eine Weile.
Auf deine neue Wohnung.
Zum Wohl.
- Auf deine Arbeit.
Aufs Abfüllen heute.
Ich bin mir nicht wirklich sicher,
ob die Umstellung auf Bio
so klug ist.
Weil ...
Meiner Meinung nach
ist es nicht wirklich ökologisch.
Die Frage ist, was wichtiger ist:
Schwefel und Kupfer spritzen
oder ökologisch sein.
Aber das ist meine Meinung.
Man muss
mit den Traktoren mehr fahren.
Man muss mehr spritzen.
Schwefel und Kupfer
sind auch Schwermetalle.
Und Schwermetalle in unseren Boden
zu versumpfen ist auch nicht so ...
Aber beim Bio-Label
geht es nicht darum.
Doch, du hast dich angemeldet.
Aber ich weiss nicht,
ob ich es drauftue,
sondern es geht darum,
dass ich keinen Ausweg mehr habe.
Ich muss es machen,
weil ich es schon drei Jahre mache.
Warum musst du es machen?
- Weil ich für mich selber ...
Es gibt keine Ausrede mehr.
- Dafür braucht's das Label?
Nein, das Label will ich nicht.
Ich werde auch nie eine Knospe
auf ein Weinetikett kleben.
Das wirst du müssen.
- Nein, muss ich nicht.
Es gibt sicher bald eine Richtlinie,
die das vorschreibt.
Es gibt für alles eine Richtlinie.
Es ist eine Vermarktung.
- Oft ist es ein Marketingkonzept.
In dem Sinne muss man den Leuten ...
Damit habe ich ein Problem.
Ich finde Naturschutz und so ja gut,
aber ich finde ...
Die Vermarktung Bio-Label und
Biodynamisch-Label ist einfach ...
... Schwachsinn.
* Bedrückende Klänge *
Und dennoch versucht Irene,
das Zertifikat zu bekommen.
Dafür muss sie
die zuständigen Behörden überzeugen,
was im Vergleich
zu ihren Kindern einfacher scheint.
* Hoffnungsvolle Klänge *
In Genf will Damien
die konsequenteste Bio-Art umsetzen:
den biodynamischen Weinbau.
Dafür besucht er
die Schule in Marcelin.
Wir behandeln
die Mikrobiologie der Weine,
die Kenntnis der Mikroorganismen
der Weine
mittels mikrobiologischer Analysen.
Wir werden versuchen,
alle Eigenschaften der Trauben
im Rahmen der Vinifizierung
zu bestimmen
und möglichst wenige Zusätze
zu verwenden, insbesondere Sulfite.
Eigentlich war es Lucs Idee.
Als ich zurückkam,
um hier zu arbeiten,
drängte er darauf, von all
diesen Herbiziden loszukommen.
Man sieht es unter dem Mikroskop.
Alles, was wir in den Rebbergen tun,
ist darauf ausgerichtet,
noch bessere Weine zu machen.
Die Frage des Zertifikats
stellt sich vermutlich erst,
wenn man sich gegenüber den Kunden
rechtfertigen muss.
Wenn man mal auf diese
chemischen Substanzen verzichtet,
dann stellt man fest, dass die Reben
wie gewünscht reagieren,
und das ermutigt einen,
auf diesem Weg weiterzuarbeiten.
So stellt sich automatisch
ein Interesse
am biodynamischen Anbau ein.
* Antreibende Musik *
Der biodynamische Anbau ist ein ganz-
heitlicher, naturfreundlicher Ansatz,
der in Beudon schon vor 50 Jahren
pionierhaft angewandt wurde.
Für den biodynamischen Anbau
braucht man spezifische Sachkenntnis.
Marion will
diesen beschwerlichen Weg gehen.
Schau selber! Es fliesst nichts.
Muss das höher oder tiefer stehen?
Höher.
- Hier fliesst's.
Haben wir nur einen Zerstäuber?
Ja.
- Der andere geht nicht? - Nein.
Öffnest du?
Du musst ziehen.
Ist es verschmutzt?
Hä?
Ich versteh dich nicht.
Verschmutzt, oben?
Ist viel Erde drin?
Heute geht alles schief.
Heute ist Montag vor Pfingsten.
Der Montagmorgen ist immer hart.
Wir machen die erste biodynamische
Behandlung dieses Jahres,
und unser Arbeiter Gentile,
der alles weiss und alles kennt,
ist krank.
Also müssen wir klarkommen,
so gut es eben geht.
So, der letzte Tropfen.
Wir haben Schachtelhalmextrakt
gemacht.
Stopp!
Wir lassen ihn
seit letztem Samstag ziehen
und bringen ihn heute zur Verhin-
derung von Pilzkrankheiten aus.
* Sanfte, hoffnungsvolle Musik *
Im biodynamischen Landbau
wird eine Pflanze
als ein auf dem Kopf
stehender Mensch betrachtet.
D.h., die Wurzeln sind der Kopf.
Die Pflanze sucht über die Wurzeln,
was die Mikroorganismen
zubereitet haben.
Mit Roundup
oder anderen starken Herbiziden
töten wir die Mikroorganismen ab.
Wir töten genau jene Stoffe ab,
die unsere Helfer sind.
Das sollten wir nicht tun.
* Langsam anschwellende,
antreibende Musik *
Das hier so einschlagen
und dann hier leicht falten.
Valentinas letzte Vorbereitungen
vor der Präsentation
ihres neuen Weissweins.
Soll ich dieses Zertifikat
zwischen die Flaschen
oder gleich zuoberst einstecken?
Zuoberst, oder?
Es war so:
Der Alkoholgehalt stimmte nicht.
Wir mussten ihn
an jeder Flasche korrigieren.
Der Arme musste das von Hand machen.
Hier.
Man sieht es, ohne hinzuschauen.
Aber das fällt doch
überhaupt nicht auf.
500 Flaschen sind so und
500 korrekt. Ein guter Kompromiss.
Eh, bello.
Ist das der letzte Karton?
- Der letzte.
Oh!
Et les jeux sont faits.
Give me five!
Cioe, dieci.
Batti cinque, pero ...
Und nun muss
noch eine würdige Ansprache her.
"Guten Tag, liebe Gäste.
Willkommen im Saal Reise der Sinne."
"Willkommen
zur dritten Ausgabe der Vinissima,
unserer grossen Frühlingsweinprobe."
"Vor ein paar Jahren war es
nur eine Idee, eine Sehnsucht."
Ich hab schon Herzklopfen.
So geht das nicht, Valentina.
"Heute ist das Projekt Realität.
Wir haben eine Produktlinie."
Nein, das gefällt mir nicht.
"Heute ist das Projekt Realität."
Todo bien?
- Ja, bei dir?
Ja, äh ...
Wie war's?
- Gut. - Okay.
Du hast Empanadas gemacht?
Ich bin dabei.
- Super.
Hilfst du mir?
- Klar.
Magst du einen Mate?
- Gerne.
Wie war dein Tag?
- Gut.
Moi, j'avais conge aujourd'hui.
Gut so?
- Grossartig.
* Sanfte Musik *
Basile und seine Frau Nadia
haben Freunde in ihren
privaten Weinkeller eingeladen.
Die Argentinierin Nadia
hat sich schnell an das Dorfleben
im Lavaux gewöhnt.
Es war sehr gut.
Du hast heute wohl Kunden gewonnen.
Jetzt der Höhepunkt: ein Malbec.
Auf dem Weingut DiamAndes
habe ich gearbeitet.
Den gab's zur Hochzeit.
Weisst du noch?
Ja, den haben wir gesunken ...
äh, getrunken!
Mein Bruder arbeitet auf dem Gut
The Vines of Mendoza in Argentinien,
und Basile war auf DiamAndes
bei der Weinlese dabei,
als er zum ersten Mal
in Argentinien war.
Ja, zuerst bei denen.
Es war sehr schön,
als Basile und ich uns 2012
in Argentinien begegneten.
Er kam aber nicht zu mir,
um sich zu verabschieden,
und so wusste ich nicht,
ob wir uns wiedersehen würden.
Das war sehr traurig.
Er hinterliess mir aber einen Brief
und eine Flasche Wein
von dem Weingut, auf dem er
gearbeitet hatte, also DiamAndes.
Seither erinnern wir uns jedes Mal
an unsere erste Begegnung,
wenn wir einen Wein von dort
trinken.
Ja, eine schöne Erinnerung.
Das ist Traubenmost
direkt nach der Weinlese.
Ist das ein oranger Wein
oder Naturwein?
Ein Naturwein, der so heisst,
weil keine Zusätze oder Sulfite
drin sind.
Sind Vitamine drin?
Da sind sicher Vitamine drin,
und ausserdem finde ich den Ansatz
dieses Winzers interessant.
Aber das zu zweit trinken zu müssen,
ist eine Qual.
Wir gehen grundsätzlich
so biologisch wie möglich vor,
aber es gibt klimatisch
sehr ungünstige Jahre,
in denen die Reben anfällig
für kryptogamische Krankheiten
wie Falschen oder Echten Mehltau
sind.
Und die chemischen Substanzen
zur Bekämpfung dieser Parasiten
sind halt sehr wirksam.
* Stimmengewirr *
Man kann es so sehen:
Ich bin nicht der Patient, der mit
einem Husten zum Arzt geht und sagt:
"Gut, ich muss wohl
eine Art Bronchitis haben,
aber Antibiotika
kommen nicht infrage."
* Stimmengewirr *
Hallo, meine Liebe.
Schön, dich zu sehen.
Wow, bellissima.
- Das ist meine Mutter.
Guten Tag, freut mich,
Valentina Tamborini.
Piacere, buongiorno.
Guten Tag und willkommen
zur dritten Ausgabe der Vinissima,
unserer grossen Frühlingsweinprobe.
Vor ein paar Jahren war es
nur eine Idee, eine Sehnsucht.
Heute ist das Projekt Realität:
die Valentina Wine Collection.
Der neue Weisswein erhält den Namen
Vivi - und das ist kein Zufall.
Mit meinem Vivi möchte ich diesmal
die Forschung im Bereich der
seltenen Krankheiten unterstützen -
in Gedenken an eine für mich
sehr bedeutende Person,
nämlich meine liebe Schwester Alice,
die uns von ihrer Wolke aus
beobachtet und mir die Kraft gibt,
meine Träume zu verwirklichen.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Et voila!
Che bello!
Te la faccio servire ...
Ich bin sehr zufrieden.
Es ist wie eine Geburt,
die Geburt meines ersten Weines.
Ich bin glücklich.
Salute! Mi fa molto piacere.
Valentina ist bei allen
gut angekommen. Mit einer Ausnahme.
Hast du
meine Vivi-Präsentation gesehen?
Nein, leider nicht,
weil ich alles Mögliche zu tun
hatte, und es war Mittagszeit.
Ich bin zufrieden.
Es hat mir sehr gut gefallen.
Mein Papa ist immer so ernst.
Er sollte mehr lächeln
und fröhlich sein.
Manchmal ist es nicht einfach.
In Graubünden versucht Irene,
positiv zu bleiben.
Trotz Uneinigkeit mit ihrer Tochter
muss sie auf Kurs bleiben.
Europa war sehr kritisch,
weil es im Jahr 2016
sehr nass war und schwierige
Bedingungen herrschten.
Das hat sie natürlich mitbekommen.
Sie dachte, es sei jedes Jahr so,
dass man praktisch
auf dem Zahnfleisch läuft.
Aber so ist es ja nicht.
Das war ein Ausnahmejahr.
Hoffentlich gibt es das
nicht mehr so schnell.
Wenn ich
an das Jahr 2016 zurückdenke,
das im Hinblick auf Bio
sehr schwierig war
und man teils
bis zu 15 Spritzungen machen musste,
die konventionell mit acht oder neun
zu machen gewesen wären,
ist meine Frage, ob sich das lohnt
und ökologisch ist.
Zu Beginn hatten wir Streitigkeiten,
weil ich anderer Meinung war
und fand, man könne gewisse Arbeiten
anders machen.
Jetzt lasse ich sie
eher einfach machen.
Ab und zu sage ich,
wie man es auch machen könnte,
dann kann sie als Chefin
entscheiden.
Wenn ich den Betrieb übernehme,
kann ich alles ändern
oder machen, wie ich es will.
Ich habe noch Zeit.
Es ist natürlich etwas anderes,
wenn man einen Nachfolger hat
als wenn man nur für sich arbeitet.
Es ist beruhigend und schön.
Man arbeitet nicht umsonst.
Es ergibt Sinn.
Es gibt einige Weinbauern,
die keine Nachkommen haben.
In Beudon
ist kein Nachfolger in Sicht.
Aber es gibt Nachkommen, denen
Marion Geheimrezepte weitergibt.
Das sind Brennnesseln.
Die stinken, oder?
Ein bisschen.
- Ich finde nicht.
Was, es stinkt nicht? Sag bloss!
Nie gesehen?
In der Schule nie gehört?
Nein, in der Schule nicht.
Brennnesseln
sind wie Sonnenstrahlen, David.
In den Mist gemischt
produzieren sie nicht nur Stickstoff
und andere Dinge.
Sie machen den Mist
auch intelligent.
Kapierst du das?
Die Erde organisiert sich selbst
schon richtig.
Ich bin die Grossmutter,
die einfach weitermacht.
Hier kommen die Brennnesseln rein.
Du musst wissen: Daraus entwickelt
sich ein grossartiger Dünger.
Klar, jede Mutter oder Grossmutter
träumt davon,
ihre Kinder und Grosskinder
einzubinden.
Aber sie können frei entscheiden.
Es gibt sicher noch Verrückte
wie Jacky und Marion,
aber wo sind sie?
Einen Zauberstab
habe ich auch nicht.
* Sanfte, hoffnungsvolle Klänge *
Winter 2018:
Das neue Jahr wird für die
Schweizer Winzer ein langes werden.
In Genf für Damien
ein Jahr der Entscheidung.
Seit vier Jahren
ist es sehr schwierig.
2013 haben wir
durch einen Hagelsturm am 20. Juni
80 % der Ernte verloren.
Das war eine schwere Last.
Es hat wehgetan und tut jedes Mal
wieder weh, wenn man daran denkt.
Wir waren in den Reben
und sahen den Sturm aufziehen.
Wir konnten nur noch
ins Auto steigen
und zuschauen,
wie die Reben zerfetzt wurden!
Es war eine Katastrophe.
Und der Frost im Jahr 2017
war eine ähnliche Katastrophe.
Es war schrecklich.
Du weisst, es wird kommen,
und kannst nichts dagegen tun.
Nur warten, beten, Kerzen anzünden
oder irgendwie
die Götter beschwören.
Dann stehst du nachts auf
und siehst, es hat -2 °C, -3 C°,
und du weisst, alles ist futsch.
Du erlebst es live mit.
Man sitzt echt wie auf Nadeln.
Natürlich, wenn es einen trifft,
dann ist man versichert,
sogar gut versichert.
Aber man hofft ja auch nicht,
dass das Haus abbrennt
oder man einen Autounfall hat,
nur weil man dagegen versichert ist.
Und ausserdem hat er ja noch
die kleinen Zwillinge.
Da muss man schon aufpassen,
nicht alles zu verlieren.
Ein schlechter Tag heute?
* Das Baby weint. *
So, weg mit den Tränen,
weg mit dem Kummer!
Schau, wie gross du bist.
Geht's dir jetzt besser?
2016 war ein grossartiges Jahr:
sehr gute Qualität, schöner Ertrag,
mit dem wir auch gutes Geschäft
machen können.
Aber man bekommt nichts geschenkt.
Ich bin also geneigt zu sagen:
Packen wir 2018 an
und vergessen wir nicht, was war.
* Langsam anschwellende,
antreibende Musik *
Der Frühling beginnt.
Damien hat das Wetter immer im Auge.
* Donnern *
Nur ein paar Meter entfernt
steht das Jahr auf Messers Schneide.
Hier die gelben Punkte.
Im Frühling geht's um den Schutz
der Knospen und damit der Zukunft.
Einige
kämpfen auf biodynamischem Weg.
Mmh, ein Zaubertrank.
Beudon liegt allein
in den Händen von Marion.
Und dort der Pfeiler,
an dem Jacques seinen Unfall hatte.
Schicksal akzeptieren ... - Es hätte
auch anderswo passieren können.
... und sich dauernd anpassen:
Darum geht es im Weinbau.
Überall in den Rebbergen der Schweiz
beginnt eine neue Jahreszeit,
in der alles möglich ist.